This is going to be a super easy and simple eyebrow tutorial...
...and great for beginners.
So, if you guys wanna see what my tips are, keep watching.
So to start off, it's really important to give your eyebrows a nice comb-through.
You can either use a clean mascara wand for this step...
...or what I like to use is the Anastasia Brow Whiz Pencil.
It's got the comb and the colored pencil on the opposite side.
After watching a ton of videos and asking my friends that are makeup artists,...
...I finally found a technique that works for my eyebrows.
So the first step is to create that line on the bottom part of your eyebrow.
Then, create a line above as well.
It's also really important to use soft and quick strokes.
You don't wanna press too hard because that will make it look too drawn on...
...and when it comes to your eyebrows, you want them to look kinda natural.
So, when you're happy with the outline, fill the inside areas with feathery strokes.
Then, flip the pencil over and use the comb...
...to go over your entire eyebrow really softly.
This part might take some time...
...so you may need to go over some areas if you need to.